hey guys Pete here mr. robot season 2
episode 7 aired last night and we got
ourselves some big answers the power in
my neighborhood got knocked out for like
5 hours by a crazy storm that went
through so my recap this time is gonna
be a little bit different I usually like
to go through the whole episode scene by
scene but due to time constraints I'm
going to do an overview of each
character instead let me know in the
comments which style you like better for
future reviews we'll start off with
Angela and Dom last we saw them dominant
approached her at her desk and wanted to
know what she was doing on a restricted
floor we pick up at the exact same place
to see that Angela is able to Stonewall
her she tells her she was on the floor
because she was making plans with the
agent that she talked to Don tells her
she knows about her background asked her
some questions that Angela doesn't
answer and then Dom backs off she tells
her that she was planning on having her
into answer some questions soon anyways
and Angela says no problem she's just
really busy right now Angela then
completes what she was doing on the
computer and Darlene says there in later
we see Dom discovered that the footage
from the 23rd floor has been erased and
she tells the agents that they've been
hacked she tells them to sweep the floor
and to check Angela's computer although
she doesn't think they're gonna find
anything
Angela heads home runs into Darlene who
tries to explain about Cisco in the CD
she offers to tell the angel anything
about eff society that she wants to know
and Angela says she already knew and
just goes inside later we see Angela at
Walmart where her dad works on the TV
screen we see a shot of the floor of
Congress on c-span they are voting on
the bailout and the balls from the bull
statue from Wall Street come crashing
through the skylight on the chamber
floor this was the big thing that f
Society was planning for the bailout
boat in DC and the shot is also
interesting because we can see the date
is 7:00 7:15 this gives us the idea that
it's it's been less than 60 days since
the hack actually happened Angela tells
her dad to have the lawyers drop the
contingency for the independent
inspections in the lawsuit so that a
court will settle her dad doesn't want
to follow her advice and she leaves it
off at things were going to happen
either way and she was just there as a
courtesy
Meenaxi Angela in prices office and we
find out the contingency had been lifted
they have a conversation where she tells
him that she wants transferred to the
risk management division so that she can
make change
is from a thing he tells her it's his
birthday and ask her if she wants to
celebrate which she says no to later we
see her in the new position where she
works her way into into a debriefing
meeting well there she tries to gain
access to files under some guys and her
request freaks everyone out so that the
director ends up having to stop the
meeting he has some words for her but it
isn't really clear what is going to
happen for her in this part of the
company we get a little bit of Joanna
story in the very beginning we see a
flashback scene material at a function
where they meet Scott and Sharon Knowles
for the first time after that we see her
on the street with the baby and a woman
comes up on the street and throws a can
of red paint on her while calling her a
capitalist Pig we get a couple of other
scenes with her and her boyfriend which
aren't very interesting the one thing we
do find out is that even though she
won't be seen with him in public she
shows him a piece of paper which is
basically divorce papers and she says
that's his birthday present I've
complained about the Johanna scenes
before so I'm I don't really see a need
to do it again we have one scene where
we see Trenton Mobley Cisco and Darlene
all together they look worried and when
Darlene comes over to view the screen
she just asked so this is supposed to be
happening tomorrow
Eliot finally gets answered for mr.
robot after pushing him to tell the
truth about what happened after the hack
after some back-and-forth he finally
says he will tell and ask Eliot what is
the last thing he remembers he says he
remembers the popcorn machine which
reminded me of the first episode of this
season mr. robot explains that they
didn't have a choice and one pushed
about how they did it tells Elliot he
was shot him Elliot makes sure to say no
it wasn't mr. robot it was actually him
who shot Tyrell I suppose this would
explain the shell casing the Dom found
at the arcade but we don't get any other
details about what happened after that
so we're not really sure if he's dead I
mean I kind of assumed that he's dead
but we don't really know that makes it a
little bit hard to figure out who's been
sending the stuff to Joana and it kind
of made a red flag for me that the
timelines might not all be consistent
with each other I really don't know so
I'm not just gonna ramble on about it we
next see Elliot in front of a terminal
ray and Lone Star forcing him to fix the
site he finishes the migration and then
when Lone Star tries to take him back to
the basement he asked ray to play a che
chess for old time sake during the game
ray thanks Elliot for being his answer
he explains that the site was his wife's
idea and that they made a decision to
let the market dictate what was sold on
the site and agreed not to look
basically they were just looking the
other way because it was bringing in a
lot of money he explains it bothered her
less than him but that he still never
looked until Elliot came along he
expressed his remorse and then ask
Elliot how much time does he have
he says they both knew exactly what was
going to happen whenever he let him back
on the computer and Elliot explains that
he you know the authorities should be
surrounding them at any minute ray then
tells him to get out of there before
they arrive and as Elliot walks out the
front door we see agents rushing in and
he explains to us that he sent an
anonymous tip after indexing part of the
website Elliot is talking to Leah on the
basketball court who's telling him that
people are after him because of the raid
a group of guys walk up and this is
pretty much where I knew the institution
theory was going to come true
so they threaten Elliot that they'll see
him later for a one-on-one the guys
mentioned being out 800 bitcoins and not
being able to get into their wallets
since the site has been taken down if
that doesn't sound like a lot keep in
mind that one Bitcoin is worth around
five hundred and seventy five dollars
right now so yeah they're talking about
almost half a million dollars and
they're basically saying that Elliot now
owes them that money we next see Elliot
in his Bible study group or he wants to
apologize to the woman who's in charge
she hugs him and explains that she sees
Elliot talking to him you know meaning
God inside his head she leaves and
Elliot calls mr. robot by saying that he
needs help he explains that he needs to
finish what he started with evil Corp
but that he doesn't know what to do they
had their normal exchange where mr.
robot tells him that he did all those
things anyways you know Elliot himself
did them and tells Elliot if he wants to
finish this he needs to leave he needs
to be a leader after that we see him
walking down the street and the gang of
guys from the basketball court push him
into an alley if you were thinking that
maybe he wasn't in jail you definitely
had to start to relent when
you see they're about to rape him at the
last minute Leon shows up and slits all
their throats and that saves him he then
tells Elio he will be getting a letter
in the mail on Tuesday and he needs to
do what it says and then mentions white
rose he says if you talk to whiterose or
when you talk to whiterose tell him that
leon did good for him like basically
leon looked out for him so we get this
connection between white rose and leon
we see Elliott's showing the letter to
Krista and we assume it says he'll be
getting out she is happy and asked him
how things are going with mr. robot he
says that they trust each other for the
first time and then mentions about the
routine and his you know at his mom's
house she gives him a serious look to
say that you know you're not really at
your mom's house and he says he knows
let me get the big reveal that so many
people have been waiting for we find out
Elliott has really been in jail
he invented the story about staying at
his mom's house so that he could be able
to deal with the situation and he tells
us that he's sorry for lying we get a
nice sequence of images that show each
of the locations from the season his
room the basketball court and so on and
we see them turn into what they really
look like in the jail as someone who was
begrudgingly coming around to this
theory I thought the scene was pretty
effective the one thing we don't see is
Ray's office or anything else related to
him but perhaps we'll get more insight
in on that like later on in a later
episode
Elliott ends things off by saying that
he that he hopes now that we can trust
each other again he said that everything
really did happen but now that leaves us
with a lot of unanswered questions I'm
not sure how I feel about it I didn't
like the institution theory because I
was afraid the show would get too
gimmicky if we're always wondering what
the big delusion is that's going on you
know but at the same time I did say that
I thought Sam s Mel does a really good
job of storytelling so that he should be
able to pull it off so in the end I'm
not sure when I pointed out my concerns
about his mother you know how she was
always sitting behind them when they
were talking so openly a few videos back
at that point I really started to make
peace with the idea I'm not sure if the
clues became more overt or if it was
just a cumulative nature of it but it
started to get hard to do ignore let's
hope that the future seasons can keep it
together with
going off the deep end in order to try
to outdo the last big decision or
delusion that it had I mean that's my
biggest fear and I just hope they you
know keep the show interesting and I do
have to hand it to the redditors he
spotted this in the very first episode
of the season I mean on the bear it was
this theory has been around since the
very first one so they were right so a
lot of questions and a lot to think
about
if Elliott shot Tyrell does that mean
he's dead where's Elliott going now
well Johanna story lead somewhere
interesting or she just being set up as
a future enemy of Elliott's
what's Dom's next move who was brave
really and will we ever see him again
I'm not sure about any of these answers
I got some some guesses and some
theories but why don't you guys let me
know what you think please like the
video if you found that interesting you
let me know in the comments which format
you like better the you know the full
scene breakdown or this sort of overview
so I didn't have as much time this week
but please subscribe to my channel for
new mr. robot videos which I put out
each week right after the episode comes
out thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon